bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi une nouvelle alerte au tsunami en
asie du sud est
un tremblement de terre de magnitude de
8,9 sur l'échelle de richter s'est
produit il ya moins de deux heures dans
l'océan indien
là encore tout frais de l'île de sumatra
en indonésie
des scènes de panique et des coupures
d'électricité sont signalés sur place
les pays alentour thaïlande sri lanka
inde ont également déclenché la l'herbe
nous y consacrerons bien sûr une grande
partie de ce journal
la fin du voyage de jacques chirac au
japon le président de la république a
appelé une nouvelle fois à voter oui à
la constitution européenne pour
sauvegarder notre modèle social dit il
aujourd'hui un quatrième sondage
confirme la poussée du nom 54 % contre
46 pour l'oubli
le lundi de pâques n'est plus férié pour
tout le monde le gard et le territoire
de belfort ont choisi de travailler
aujourd'hui pour préserver le week-end
de pentecôte mais les écoles sont
restées presque vides et les
administrations ont tourné au ralenti
la tente se poursuit à monaco le dernier
bulletin de santé du prince rainier
évoque un état stationnaire mais
préoccupant ces médecins reste réservé
sur ses chances de survie
enfin peut être une piste pour retarder
la maladie d'alzheimer ou d'autres du
même type d expérience venez sur un
verre ont permis d'isoler une substance
qui semble efficace l'alertent et donc
générale ce soir en asie du sud trois
mois après le raz-de-marée dévastateur
un nouveau tremblement de terre vient de
se produire au nord de l'île de sumatra
en indonésie un séisme très puissant
même s'il est moins fort que le
précédent les premiers éléments d'abord
avant de retrouver
fabienne sintès en direct à banda aceh
les premiers éléments avec claude son
père
le séisme s'est produit peu avant 19
heures heure française un séisme très
violent 8 points 2 sur l'échelle de
richter le tremblement de terre s'est
produit au large de l'île de sumatra en
indonésie
pas d'image pour le moment il était 23
heures heure locale lorsque la secousse
s'est produite
c'est la même zone que l'on voit ici qui
avait déjà été touché le 26 décembre
dernier lors du raz de marée qui avait
frappé la région après un séisme à
l'époque de 9 sur l'échelle de richter
c'est un très gros tremblement de terre
et qui peut être considéré aujourd'hui
comme une réplique de celui qui s'est
produit au mois de décembre dans la même
région
il se produit ce genre de tremblement de
terre d'hier a plus d'une fois et encore
par an 29 est quelque chose de tout à
fait exceptionnel
donc ce tremblement terre qui vient de
se produire est considéré comme une
réplique par qui est d'une magnitude
inférieure par qu'il se produit dans la
même région et qu'il a probablement la
même origine technique
à l'heure actuelle on ignore s'il ya des
victimes
une alerte au tsunami a été lancée en
thaïlande en indonésie au sri lanka et
en malaisie
ce sont les américains du centre d'
alerte d'hawaï qu'il ait promis en
données l'alertent il parle à l'heure
actuelle d'un risque de raz-de-marée
dévastateur pour les pays de la région
l'agencé américaine vient d'appeler tous
les pays du secteur est évacuée
d'urgence les populations vivant le long
des côtes
pour éviter une tratégie tragédie
équivalente au 26 décembre dernier
alors nous retrouvons fabienne sintès
grand reporter à france inter et france
info à banda aceh bonsoir fabienne est
ce que vous m'entendez bord soit nous
votons bien oui vous êtes donc situer on
l'a compris tout près de l'épicentre du
séisme
est-ce que des scènes de panique ont été
constatés ce que vous ne les avez vus à
ça a été extrêmement impressionnant la
secousse on l'a tous évidemment centimes
et vous savez que des répliques
il y en a beaucoup dans cette région de
manière extrêmement fréquentes celles ci
tout le monde a senti qu'elle commençait
à durer bien plus longtemps et on vous
peut-être de 45 secondes tout le monde
s'est retrouvé dans la rue les gens se
regardaient j'ai vu une femme
s'agenouiller subitement et se mettre à
prier des enfants commencé à pleurer et
puis dans la fraction de seconde qui a
suivi alors que la terre tremblait
encore les ombres se sont tous rués sur
leurs véhicules tout ce qui roule les
voitures les toutous qu'il ya ici les
les
est également et tout le monde est parti
tous l'accès merlan des files entières
de voitures qui disait il et tous on
part vers le nord on part vers la
montagne il faut monter ils soient
montés la vague arrive ce moment de
panique a duré dix ans cette grosse qu'à
nice une bonne demi heure j'étais moi
dans la voiture de mon interprète ici
par exemple ce qui est parti avec
évidemment sa femme et ses deux enfants
sa femme avant de prendre au vol
elle appelle son sac d'urgence en cas de
tsunami réellement avec son compte en
banque à l'intérieur avec des bijoux
également et les clés de la maison et
tout le monde est parti comme ça il a
fallu vraiment une bonne heure pour que
la tension retombe 7/4 en ce moment les
gens rentrent doucement chez eux sans
pour autant rentrer dans leur maison il
est un peu tôt pour eux pour se
retrouver tout seul d'une certaine façon
c'est important pour eux d'être ensemble
encore à ce moment là et ce qu'on voit
passer ici dans le centre-ville où je me
trouve ce sont des voitures de police
ils disent aux gens calmez vous calmez
vous il n'ya pas de tsunami tout va bien
calmez vous et est ce qu'on pense
effectivement qu'un tsunami a des
chances de se produire compte tenu de la
configuration des lieux ça n'est pas
exactement la même cote
ou est ce que finalement ces scènes de
panique ne sont pas vraiment justifié or
excès du l'état de cette population est
encore extrêmement traumatisés juste
qu'ils ont vécu mais s'il faut se
souvenir quand même que j'aime je me
trouve en ce moment par exemple où les
gens sont dehors en train de discuter
entre eux de cette nouvelle réplique aux
là où je me trouve il n'y avait
absolument rien si ce n'est un seul qui
était absolument jonchées de cadavres
donc je pense que les gens à ce moment
là ne se pose pas la question de savoir
si la puissance était suffisamment loin
ou prem's il ya un risque qu'ils ont
peur
itani immédiatement et ils veulent même
pas cherché à comprendre gens vont
immédiatement même encore une fois le
l'interprète qui est avec nous qui
travaille beaucoup avec les les
organisations non gouvernementales avec
les journalistes qui a une vraie
connaissance des choses maintenant même
lui est parti en l'espace de quelques
secondes seulement il n'est pas qu'il
n'est pas question de raisonnement ici
en fait et c'est même nous qui avons
appris au fur et à mesure aux gens d'ici
quelle est l amplitude de ce séisme le
chauffeur notamment par exemple vous
donner une idée regarder constamment
s'annonce et nous demander la dernière
fois la vague est arrivée combien de
temps après le tremblement père dites
moi combien de temps après le
tremblement père il a fallu
constamment leurs assurés comme les
autres il a une bonne heure avant que ce
qu'elle n'est réellement et puis il faut
rappeler que compte tenu du décalage
horaire on est en pleine nuit là-bas en
indonésie est ce que on a des
informations à banda aceh fabienne sur
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté c'est à
dire au nord de sumatra tôt près de
l'épicentre
pas du tout pas du tout dit si c'est
extrêmement compliqué les téléphones se
sont retrouvés bloqués extrêmement
rapidement
il est finalement plus facile d'obtenir
la chance par téléphone que d'avoir des
gens d'un point à un autre bon coup pas
du tout ce que j'ai en face de moi par
exemple fait que les gens sont sur le
pont enfin regarder la mer en fait et
regarder vers potentiellement ce qu'ils
imaginent être le côté de l'épicentre
pour voir s'il vous arrivait quelque
chose mais non on dit si pour l'instant
on n'a absolument aucune nouvelle en
tout cas autour de moi pour ce qui est
du tremblement de terre en soit aucun
dégage une complète là là où je me
trouve encore une fois aucun dégât
permis de se faire descendre un petit
peu cette famille qu'effectivement il
maison commence à s'imaginer qu'on est
fait pour tuer confirme en tout cas il
le danger est écarté
merci fabien de synthèse pour ce
témoignage et on vous retrouvera si nous
établissons si nous gardons cette
liaison vous retrouvera bien sûr à la
fin de ce journal pour d'autres
précisions un détour tout de suite par
djakarta la capitale de l'indonésie où
nous retrouvons julie lebègue de
l'unicef
est-ce que vous avez des précisions à
jakarta sur ce que pourraient être les
premiers dégâts et du tremblement de
terre et de la vague qui s'en est suivi
pour l'instant nous n'avons aucune
précision en termes de dégâts sur ce qui
s'est passé
elle soumettra à banda aceh sur la côte
ouest à malabo à jakarta nous n'avons
rien senti aucune secousse nous avons
été informés par nos équipes tout et se
trouve actuellement à banda aceh en
particulier effectivement les gens ont
paniqué continue à paniquer ils sont
dans la rue et on doit lui et est
actuellement un peu plus d'une heure du
matin ce qui est assez une usure elle à
banda aceh les gens attendent en fait
attendre de voir si l'eau va arriver il
est extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
liens avec la côte ouest de d'athris
pour l'instant donc nous pouvons pas
savoir pour rapporter des dégâts sur
cette coupe
merci julie lebègue on l'a compris le
séisme s'est produit à quelques dizaines
ou quelques centaines de kilomètres du
précédent ce serait en fait une réplique
d'après l'agencé américaine de
surveillance géologique depuis le 26
décembre en tout cas tout le monde a
appris que les vagues
arrive très vite sur les côtes laurence
de l'heure il est 8h 50 du matin le 26
décembre 2004 une succession de vagues
géantes ravage les pros de l'asie du
sud-est en quelques heures
c'est un séisme d'une magnitude de 8,9
sur l'échelle de richter qui est à
l'origine de cette catastrophe
il s'est produit au large de l'île de
sumatra en indonésie
l'ong se déplace à 800 kilomètres heure
les pays voisins sont rapidement toucher
la thaïlande en moins d'une heure le sri
lanka en deux heures l'un du sud en
trois heures que s'est il passé
une énorme masse rocheuse s'est élevé de
quelques mètres sous l'eau une énergie
incroyable c'est alors libéré l'ondé de
choc s'est répandue et amplifier
jusqu'aux côtes provoquant des vagues
qui mesurent plusieurs mètres de haut
les sismologues américains avaient
enregistré le séisme et tentaient de
prévenir les pays concernés mais en vain
seul le japon à l'époque était doté d'un
système d' alerte
la catastrophe a fait plus de 270 mille
morts et disparus dont près de la moitié
en indonésie et en duplex nous
retrouvons jean christophe rufin
président d'action internationale contre
la faim un bonsoir jean christophe rufin
vous avez en ce moment des équipes en
indonésie dont une quinzaine de
personnes à meulaboh c'est à dire au
plus près de l'endroit où se seraient
produits ce nouveau séisme
est ce que vous avez pu entrer en
contact avec vos équipes à ce que vous
avez des informations non pas encore
parce que comment l'année tout à l'heure
c'est le milieu de la nuit nos équipes
en fait sont très très proches sont
échelonnés tout le long de la côte entre
banda aceh et donc meulaboh depuis et le
séisme d'ailleurs on peut dire nous
assurons l'approvisionnement nourriture
de cette zone et nous avons 23 personnes
devaient prendre indonésie dont 15 à
malabo et les liaisons téléphoniques
sont difficiles apparemment les lignes
ont été coupées
absolument c'est très difficile de les
joindre ce que je dois dire quand même
c'est que nous avons pris des
précautions depuis 2006 mais normalement
il avait pour consigne ils ont eu pour
consigne pendant très longtemps même
quand il ya des bâtiments en dur de
dormir sous tente
parce que il y avait en permanence des
petites répliques qui n'atteignait pas
évidemment l'importance de celle-ci
donc c'est tout ce qui me laisse espérer
qu'en effet ils ont été ils ont été
protégés
merci jean christophe rufin vous
retrouvera peut-être vous aussi d'ici la
fin de ce journal si vous parvenez à
rentrer en contact avec vos équipes
si vous nous rejoignez je vous rappelle
l'information donc de cette soirée un
nouveau séisme tout près de l'île de
sumatra en indonésie 8 2 à 8 points 5
sur l'échelle de richter selon les
sources nous n'avons pas d'indication
pour l'instant sur d'éventuels dégâts
en tout cas l'alertent au tsunami est
générale en asie du sud
tous les pays concernés par le premier
tsunami l'on déclenché bien entendu
l'indonésie mais aussi le sri lanka la
thaïlande et le sud de l'inde voilà ce
qu'on pouvait dire à cette heure ci nous
y revenons bien sûr à la fin de ce
journal dans quelques minutes
l'autre actualité de cette journée je
vous le disais en titre c'est d'abord ce
quatrième sondage qui confirme la
poussée du nom en vue du référendum sur
la constitution européenne selon cette
enquête ipsos pour le figaro à europe 1
le non l'emporterait aujourd'hui avec
54% des voix contre 46,3 points à noter
d'abord le sondage a été réalisé
vendredi et samedi donc après le sommet
européen où la directive bolkestein a
été écartée ensuite c'est à gauche que
le nom progresse le plus c'est pour la
première fois il est majoritaire chez
les sympathisants socialistes
enfin un tiers des personnes interrogées
certaines d'aller voter n'ont pas
exprimé d'intention de vote ce qui peut
faire relativiser cette indication alors
cette poussée du nom a dominé le voyage
de jacques chirac au japon le chef de
l'état y est revenu ce matin encore
juste avant de repartir
alix bouilhaguet
jacques chirac un tiers à cet instant
son principal souci c'est l'issue du
combat de sumos de poids lourd face à
face dans une lutte aussi incertaine
qu'une autre bataille cette fois
politique le référendum sur la
constitution européenne de cela il ne
devait pas en parler pourtant dès le
premier jour jacques chirac n'a pas
hésité à dramatiser l'enjeu du scrutin
est l'occasion de dire aux françaises et
aux français tout le sérieux avec lequel
il faut réfléchir à cette question
une première petites phrases distillées
à dix mille kilomètres de paris le fait
est inhabituelle hier soir jacques
chirac ne s'est pas arrêté là il a même
exhorté clairement les français à dire
oui à la constitution européenne
l'occasion dé de dire aux françaises et
aux français pourquoi de mon point de
vue l'intérêt de la france de l'europe
mais aussi de la paix du développement
et de la sauvegarde de notre modèle
social suppose l'adhésion se pose de
répondre oui au traité constitutionnel
pour ce oui même au japon
jacques chirac a déjà commencé à faire
campagne
la poussée du non confirmées dans les
sondages devrait l'inciter à s'engager
encore plus dès son retour en france
alors on entend souvent que personne en
france ne connaît cette constitution et
bien chaque soir de cette semaine nous
allons là détaillé point par point et on
commence ce soir par le commencement
pourquoi une nouvelle constitution et
pourquoi aujourd'hui pauline revenant
daniel leno
octobre 2004 le texte de la constitution
est signée à romans mais d'où vient
cette constitution 47 ans plus tôt même
ville même lieu symbolique le traité de
rome consacre l'europe des six france
allemagne italie et trois pays du
benelux après le charbon et l'acier
l'agriculture moteur de la construction
le couple franco-allemand de gaulle
adenauer très sceptique sur un éventuel
projet politique
bien entendu on peut sauter sur sa
chaise comme un cabri en disant leur
rappelant de l'europe mais ça n'aboutit
à rien au fil des années le projet
européen prend de l'ampleur la
constitution l'europe en at elle besoin
les traités se suivent pas moins de
quatre en 15 ans l'acte unique créer un
espace de libre échange
mme astrid j'invente l'euro à amsterdam
on parle d'environnement et de droits
sociaux
a nice c'est l'élargissement à 25 une
structure de plus en plus complexes
d'où la nécessité pour ses partisans de
simplifier ses textes et d'adopter une
constitution européenne
c'est indispensable si on considère
qu'il faut un mécanisme permettant de
décider plus efficacement et plus
démocratiquement le problème de la
constitution réplique ses détracteurs
c'est sa légitimité pour qu'il y ait une
constitution fo qui est un peuple c'est
un peuple qui se donne une constitution
en europe il ya 25 peuple à part un
peuple européen
comment cette constitution at-elle été
négociée autour de valéry giscard
d'estaing 105 personnes essentiellement
des parlementaires se sont réunis
pendant 17 mois c'est cette convention
qui a élaboré les 448 articles de la
constitution européenne
la ville de nîmes et le département du
gard se sont donc distinguer du reste de
la france aujourd'hui puisque ce lundi
de pâques et est en théorie un jour
comme les autres là bas petit rappel
d'abord pour financer l'aide aux
personnes âgées ou handicapées le
gouvernement a supprimé un jour férié en
l'occurrence le lundi de pentecôte mais
le gars bénéficie d'une dérogation pour
préserver la feria de nîmes organisé
précisément la pentecôte alors pour la
première fois ont travaillé donc
aujourd'hui mais apparemment tout le
monde n'a pas suivi sur place à nîmes
les eaux lamberton parce qu'elle pense
c'est la bonne nouvelle de ce lundi de
pâques à nîmes
la préfecture est ouverte mais
visiblement personne ne le sait faire
ses papiers n'a jamais été aussi rapide
c'était une journée idéale ouais parce
que c'est un prix prennent pas cinq
minutes ce matin devant ce collège
l'ambiance était nettement moins joyeuse
les cars de ramassage scolaire sont
quasiment vides
les parents ont boycotté ce lundi de
pâques travailler pour leurs enfants
comme d'habitude plein hélas quand même
vous n'avez coût des frais de transport
pour aujourd'hui
cent mille euros 12 oui c'est une
gabegie extraordinaire parce que nous
allons aujourd'hui 500 cartes qui sont
mobilisés il ya pratiquement pas
d'élèves demain donc cette journée de
solidarité est enlevée par commun du
gars et c'est vraiment le grand bazar
ici 90 % des enfants sont absents 20 %
des professeurs en grève
fixé aujourd'hui dans le gard et non le
lundi de pentecôte à cause de la feria
de nîmes
la journée de solidarité pour les
personnes âgées n'enthousiasme personnes
c'est de la peine parce que bon
traditionnellement c'était un week-end
de fête familiale moi personnellement je
suis de normandie la famille est
descendu voilà et moi je suis là c'est
n'importe quoi c'est ça partout ses
seins nus parfois en fait dans le gard
aujourd'hui beaucoup d'entreprises
administrations sont restés fermés
même les horodateurs animent sont
gratuits comme si ce lundi de pâques
était encore férié et le gard on disait
n'est pas tout à fait seul dans cette
situation le territoire de belfort ou
encore les villes de vic fezensac et de
moissac ont aussi fait ce choix et là
aussi les administrations sont restées
désertes images ici du collège lycée de
moissac où à peine 10% des élèves
étaient en classe
aujourd'hui le temps semble suspendu ce
soit encore à monaco où l'on vit
toujours au rythme des bulletins de
santé du prince rainier le dernier
publié aujourd'hui évoque un état
stationnaire mais préoccupant les
monégasques avaient été nombreux hier à
prier pour leurs souverains mais pour le
reste la vie suit son cours
l'incertitude est latente n'ont pas
empêché ce week-end de pâques de koné
une très forte affluence sur place
yasmina farber philippe chasselas la
place du casino ne désemplit pas le
lundi de pâques une escapade à monaco
c'est presque un rituel surtout pour les
italiens les visiteurs sont plus
amateurs de belles voitures que deux
gazettes people état de santé du prince
rainier semble étranger à cette
affluence du jour
c'est du moins l'avis d'un professionnel
sur la plage du larvotto
les terrasses sont bondées un air d'été
des mines détendu comme pour dire que la
vie continue même si le prince est au
plus mal
c'est d'abord un moment privé pour la
famille à vivre dans l'intimité
malgré ça on est sur la plage c'est
l'avis de monaco ainsi de bons moments
monte carlo et triste triste même si la
journée est radieuse ont bien sûr c'est
que quand on passe devant le but
acrobatique quelque chose les médias
badie sur le port sont suspendues aux
nouvelles du palais princier
en fin de journée le ciel bleu avait
disparu sous un épais brouillard
comme un retour brutal à la réalité les
médecins du centre cardio-thoracique
juge toujours préoccupant l'état de
santé du prince rainier il est
maintenant sous dialyse rénale et reste
sous assistance respiratoire
un rom les cérémonies de pacs ont
terminé jean paul ii n'a pas participé à
la bénédiction du lundi et les images du
pape hier visage grimaçant contraint au
silence ont beaucoup impressionné
certains se demandent même s'il faut
montrer cette souffrance et si le saint
père est vraiment maître de ses
apparitions
isabelle staes christophe la rockhal le
lundi de pâques il arrive parfois que
jean paul ii donne sa bénédiction à midi
pour clôturer la semaine sainte les
fenêtres du pape sont restées fermées
aujourd'hui
mais tous ici garde en mémoire cette
image jean paul ii qui tentent de parler
en vain je ne pense pas que ce serait
indécent parce que même dans son ultime
effort
l'essentiel est que sa mémoire sont
encore capables de penser à ce que doit
être la vie de l'église le dimanche des
rameaux jean paul ii avait montré un
signe d'énervement en frappant son
pupitre geste de colère d'un homme trahi
par son corps
le pape n'a pas prononcé un mot depuis
quinze jours et le vendredi-saint il
tournait le dos aux fidèles mais la
plupart d'entre eux le croit encore
capable de gouverner l'église
c'est un beau symbole c'est un monde que
jusqu'au bout il veut jouer son rôle et
jeu c'est plutôt un signe d'espoir et
c'est positif
le pape a perdu la santé la voix mais
ses apparitions aujourd'hui résulte de
sa seule volonté
le pape veut continuer à essayer c'est
comme le l'athlète qui a échoué une
preuve il demande d'en faire une autre
parce que enfin le un pape qui naquit
n'avait plus de contact avec les gens ce
serait pour lui un pape mor jamais
l'image de jean paul ii n'aura été aussi
inquiétante mais face un bape
extrêmement affaibli personne n'ose plus
ici parler de démission ce lundi de
pâques est aussi traditionnellement une
journée chargée sur les routes du retour
circulation très dense aux abords des
grandes villes ici l'a13 près de paris
mais on a déjà vu des bouchons plus
impressionnant
apparemment les conseils de bison futé
ont tout de même été prise en compte et
certains se souviendront de leurs
vacances ou de leur week end
ainsi ces deux skieurs qui avait pris le
que les sièges en fin de journée aux
arcs pour faire une ultime descente
ils ont été oubliés et sont restés toute
la nuit
perché à plus de 4 mètres au dessus du
sol l'employé étourdie a été sanctionné
aujourd'hui benoît gallerey thierry
monnier sur place ils sont venus de la
région parisienne pour passer un
week-end pascal à la montagne samedi
vers 17h john et claude empreinte ce
télésiège pour une dernière descente à
une centaine de mètres de l'arrivée la
machine s'arrête
les employés viennent de couper le
moteur avant de fermer les pistes
on a essayé de crier de faire de se
faire entendre pour par rapport au
perche mal mais on était vraiment trop
éloignée on s'est tenus éveillés l'un
l'autre on voulait pas dormir
et puis on parlait toute la nuit on
essaie vraiment de garder l'esprit l'esc
l'optimiste roi
les deux skieurs n'ont pas de téléphone
portable et leur position à quatre
mètres au dessus du sol ne les incite
pas à sauter ils seront retrouvés le
lendemain matin en légère hypothermie la
température nocturne étant descendu à -
4 degrés cette mésaventure est due à un
employé il a vu les deux derniers
skieurs partir mais par erreur a indiqué
un mauvais numéro poste d'arrivée nous
ont fait 16 millions de passages par an
seront remontées mécaniques
il ya ma connaissance depuis 15 ans elle
n'était pas arrivée
l'employé fautif a été suspendue car
l'incident aurait pu être dramatique si
la température avait été inférieur les
deux skieurs n'ont pas porté plainte
il négocie actuellement un arrangement à
l'amiable avec la direction de la
station
un appel qui fait des vagues maintenant
après les agressions des casseurs contre
des lycéens lors des dernières
manifestations
sept personnalités ont lancé une
pétition elle dénonce d'un racisme anti
blanc racisme anti blanc c'est la
première fois que cette expression est
mise en avant et que le phénomène est
dénoncé pour les signataires
il faut en finir avec l'angélisme et les
tabous mais cet appel est vivement
dénoncée par plusieurs associations qui
parle de stigmatisation et de
simplification
loïc de la mornais edouard ferrand
derrière ces visages en sang et ses
insultes
n'y at il que du vandalisme ordinaire ou
bien du racisme
après les échauffourées des dernières
manifestations lycéennes ou plusieurs
jeunes auraient été agressés et traiter
de sale français une radio et une
association juive ont diffusé un appel
contre le racisme anti blanc ses auteurs
estiment n'avoir lancé qu'un cri
d'alarmé se défendent de toute
récupération ou arrière pensées
politiques
je ne chercherai
je cherche simplement à défendre un
petit sébastien comme depuis maintenant
40 ans en bas que j'ai dû commencer
probablement à militer dans l'anti
racisme au collège j'ai défendu des
petits david des petits kader des petits
boubaker ben pour moi c'est la même
chose
plusieurs personnalités ont déjà signé
cet appel comme bernard kouchner
le cinéaste elie chouraqui le philosophe
alain finkielkraut ou encore jacques
julliard jetons a voulu c'est marquer le
coup il fallait marquer le coup car
l'espèce de silence gêné bien pensants
ans vous savez il faut pas en parler
parce que ce sont des jeunes de banlieue
ça c'est comme andy contre-productif ça
fait le contraire de ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est à dire lutter contre le
racisme mais la plupart des
organisations lycéennes ne sont pas de
cet avis et réfute toute idée d'un
racisme anti blanc pas oublier
qu'aujourd'hui en france les gens qui
souffrent le plus du racisme ce ne sont
pas les blancs entre guillemets
ce sont évidemment les blacks les beurs
qui viennent de ghettos qui viennent des
cités et qui tous les jours souffrent du
racisme que ce soit dans la rue au
présent une personne que ce soit à
l'embauché que ce soit pour l'emploi etc
etc
les associations antiracistes rappelle
que chaque manifestation amène son lot
de casseurs ou de personnes venues
chercher la bagarre
elle refuse par exemple de voir dans ce
coup de poing un acte raciste
il s'agit d'un vol de portable à propos
du mouvement lycéen cette nouvelle
manifestation aujourd'hui dans un cadre
disons prestigieux 200 élèves protestant
contre la loi fillon ont organisé une
opération péage gratuit au viaduc de
millau et ils ont distribué des tracts
aucun incident ni bouchon n'a été
signalé autre mouvement celui les
salariés et notamment des fonctionnaires
pour le pouvoir d'achat
le gouvernement vous le savez doit faire
des propositions aux syndicats demain
mais l'essentiel a déjà filtré
la revalorisation serait de 0,8 ou 0,9
pour cent et il y aurait aussi une prime
pour les agents dans l'évolution de
carrière est bloquée christelle martin
au rendez vous
à l'hôpital 90 mille agents devraient
toucher prochainement une prime prévue
par le gouvernement
elle s'adresse à ceux qui arrivent au
sommet de leur carrière et qui ne
peuvent plus prétendre à une promotion
de l'excellence à travers
j'espère que ça va durer ce pas que moi
j'arrive à ce point là si on nous la
donne on l'apprend mais bon donc si on
ne l'augmenté tous les mois je trouve
que d'avoir la prime en plus du secteur
hospitalier cette prime exceptionnelle
concernera certains agents les
collectivités territoriales et ceux
travaillant pour l'état
en tout sur cinq millions de
fonctionnaires 260 milles devrait
bénéficier de ce coup de pouce soit 1,2
pour cent de leur salaire annuel
ce bonus qui pourra atteindre jusqu'à
230 euros
et pourtant jugé insuffisant par les
syndicats c'est uniquement une prime si
on veut attraper le pouvoir machin lui
faut augmenter la valeur du point
d'indicé comment à tous donc le salaire
c'est ce qui sera au coeur des
négociations demain entre les syndicats
et le ministre de la fonction publique
renaud dutreil
il devrait annoncer une hausse de 0,8 à
0,9 pour cent de leur traitement
cette revalorisation viendra s'ajouter
aux 1 % d'augmentation de salaire déjà
accordés pour cette année
à l'étranger d'abord la kirghizie où les
nouveaux dirigeants consolident leur
pouvoir le nouvel homme fort au monde
bakiev et à s'est vu confier le poste de
premier ministre par intérim et l'ancien
parlement a été suspendu on s'est
beaucoup demandé depuis quelques jours
quel a été le rôle des associations et
notamment des ong américaines déjà très
active on le sait pour appuyer la
révolution ukrainienne et géorgienne est
bien l'une de nos équipes a retrouvé
certains de ses militants
apparemment ils ont bien joué un rôle
mais ils ont été eux mêmes surpris par
l'accélération des événements envoyés
spéciaux annepont 6 mai xavier ruiz et
si en plus de la pauvreté la corruption
la fraude électorale
il y avait une autre cause à la
révolution kirghize le travail des
américains qui depuis quelques années
finances au kirghizstan des programmes
de promotion de la démocratie
mike stone est l'un d'entre eux membre
de la puissante ong freedom house il
gère une imprimerie données par les
états unis ici les journaux d'opposition
viennent se faire imprimer sans censure
d'aucune sorte nous dit on pourvu qu'ils
payent tout cela peut-être favorisé la
révolution admet mike stone
mais ce n'est pas l'opposition qu'on a
encouragé ici c'est le pluralisme
imprimer le journal de celui qui entre
par cette porte quel qu'il soit c'est ça
notre objectif comme je l ai toujours
dit je serais ravi d'imprimer le journal
du kirghizstan le journal gouvernemental
s'ils veulent travailler avec nous mais
il refuse peut-être qu'avec le nouveau
gouvernement ils changeront d'avis on
fait notre boulot c'est tout mais et
alexandre kim patron d'un journal
d'opposition le sait bien
si les américains ont pu réaliser cette
imprimerie c'est que tout de même le
président akaïev était suffisamment
ouvert pour le permettre il doit
regretter d'avoir autorisé l'ouverture
de cette imprimerie américaine les
américains ont d'autres intérêts au
kirghizstan une base militaire support
logistique pour les opérations en
afghanistan
une base où l'on construit en dur mais
officiellement pas pour rester en tout
cas les américains ici ne faut pas de
lien entre leurs activités militaires et
leur promotion de la démocratie
les américains sont plutôt fiers du
travail réalisé au kirghizstan pour eux
il n'y a pas de mal à défendre la
démocratie
ils disent même qu'il préférerait ne pas
être les seuls à le faire mais ici par
exemple la disquette les démocraties
occidentales notamment la france ne sont
pas représentés par une ambassade
un rappel comme tous les jours en irak
notre consoeur florence aubenas et son
guide hussein hanoun sont retenus depuis
81 2 jours maintenant
santé un espoir je vous le disais en
titre pour soigner les maladies
dégénératives du cerveau comme alzheimer
ou inti huntington une substance
contenue dans le raisin noir pourrait
peut-être constituer un traitement
efficace pour retarder l'évolution de la
maladie c'est une équipe française qui
l'a constaté après des expériences
menées sur un verre minuscule jean
daniel flaysakier nathalie guay proposé
un verre à ces chercheurs il ne vous le
refuserons jamais cette équipe travaille
en effet sur le cnra british élégance un
verre de 1 mm de long et dont 50% des
gènes sont identiques aux nôtres
et il pourrait bien nous aider à traiter
des maladies dégénératives du cerveau
comme la maladie de huntington dans
cette affection le patient souffre de
mouvements anormaux incessant de plus en
plus sévères en cause une erreur de
programmes par les cellules nerveuses
le programme génétique de ces neurones
va en quelque sorte bégayer répétant des
dizaines de fois le même message cette
erreur déclenché une série de réactions
chimiques qui conduisent à la mort du
tissu nerveux
les chercheurs ont créé des verts
porteurs de cellules identiques à celles
des patients le ver malades se comporte
bizarrement quand on le pique il ne
s'échappe pas il continue son chemin
mais c'était sans compter sur le
resvératrol
nourri de cette poudre blanche le vert a
retrouvé un comportement normal
la preuve qu'en tant le pic d'un côté il
repart dans l'autre sens
le resvératrol protège la cellule
nerveuse malades de la destruction
ça pourrait être intéressant dans la
maladie de huntington puisqu'on y
pensent aujourd'hui éventuellement dans
d'autres maladies comme alzheimer ou
parkinson est ce qu'on peut espérer
c'est que en cas de confirmation de
l'intérêt de ces mécanismes d'action
c'est en fait une ralentissement des
symptôme de l'évolution de la maladie
le resvératrol chacun d'entre nous en
consomment régulièrement ryoma dans la
peau du raisin noir et aussi dans le vin
rouge mais les chercheurs se gardent de
conclusions hâtives
le resvératrol pour un verre ça va pour
l'homme
attendons les résultats la lutte contre
le sida avec comme chaque année le
sidaction qui démarre en fin de semaine
jacques chirac a relancé aujourd'hui son
idée de taxe pour alimenter un fonds
d'actions internationales l'afrique vous
le savez reste le continent le plus
touché par la maladie
exemple en centrafrique où plus de 15%
de la population est atteinte
apparemment les esprits commencent à
évoluer dans ce pays à 25% catholique un
prêtre et une religieuse ont déclaré la
guerre au sida
et il appelle un chat un chat envoyés
spéciaux eric monier elle francis rang
ce jour là les petites écolières de
sainte-thérèse recevait un singulier
visiteurs nelson orphelins du sida avec
mes parents ça allait très bien je les
aimais beaucoup aussi et même beaucoup
et voilà que nous appellent plus 18 ans
papa et nüssli
hier à 22 un récit volontairement cru
rien n'est épargné assez petite fille de
9 ans le père gustave l'a voulu ainsi
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de ces
conférences régulièrement organisées
dans les écoles de bangui
une initiative qui a de quoi surprendre
dans des établissements catholiques
d'ordinaire plus frileux aujourd'hui
c'est la fin d'étape
pour marcher dans les choses on voit
partout elle de saboter attendu il ya
quinze ans maintenant par l'état
d'ailleurs quand on a commencé à en
parler en 97 c'était a pu entonner
commandes dans une école catholique
on parle de prévert la fifa parle de
sexe l'allemand maintenant ce sont les
parents qui ne nous remercie d'ailleurs
parlé d'abord révélé leurs enfants à
toucy de sable elle a consigné sauver
des vies peut-être à certains moments ça
correspond à quel bateau fidélité accès
aux préservatifs silence après le
témoignage poignant des jeux finiront de
sensibiliser les enfants aux dangers un
danger bien réel en centrafrique
on estime que 15 % de la population est
infectée et huit ans de guerre civile
n'ont rien arrangé
alors le père gustave a décidé de faire
de la lutte contre la maladie
son sacerdoce après l'école il anime une
association de femmes séropositives
souvent rejeté par la famille le village
leur apportant soutien matériel et moral
moi je crois que c'est mon travail c'est
le passé le mahdi de la messe et que moi
là l'édition s'est construit s'il ya un
développement
j'ai envie 20 p c'est ça la vie change
j'ai aussi pensé ça contre une moyenne
de dieu c'est une basse aux magpies
ritualisé dire quoi aller aussi loin
mais que le bleu la personne puis vive
le paradis aujourd'hui m
pour financer son association
le père gustave n'hésite pas à mettre
les pieds et les mains dans la boucle de
ce petit rizières sortira assez de riz
pour nourrir ses paroissiens malade un
petit surplus à vendre pour pouvoir
envoyer leurs enfants à l'école
l'environnement en france la bête ça me
tire la sonnette d'alarmé contre les
camping cars depuis quelques années des
vacanciers viennent s'installer sur un
terrain sauvage en bord de mer pas d'eau
pas de poubelles encore moins de
sanitaires mais apparemment cela ne
décourage personnes ce week-end encore
il y avait près de 200 véhicules ce qui
provoque la colère des riverains
stéphanie davoigneau enfin il s'agirait
y en a qui longe qui leur tenait devant
canal hier jo lisible la guerre est
déclarée
d'un côté les riverains de l'autre 200
vacanciers qui ont pris leurs habitudes
sur ce terrain problème ici ce n'est pas
un camping
il n'y a donc pas de sanitaires ni même
de bordes aménagé pour les toilettes
nous on est là pour quatre jours n'a
suffisamment le nomic quatre jours
martyr allal nécessaire vivez votre
dernière est con à entretenir des années
qu'il pratique ici le camping sauvage et
non pas de raison de s'inquiéter puisque
la mairie a toujours laissé faire nous
ne sommes pas d'aider la corse et douze
hommes et je vais lui ya c'est vrai que
bon resto c'est vrai que vous souhaitez
un petit peu mais on aimerait j'accepte
sans suite pour le moment on laisse
faire j'en avais pu on avait essayé de
voir si on pouvait aménagé constater et
niveler le terrain et mettre une borne
le hastag l'assainissement et l'eau je
sais pas si on arrive à le faire des
aménagements pourtant indispensable car
en france le nombre de camping-cars a
doublé en cinq ans ces caravanes en tout
cas ne sont plus très mobiles le bout du
voyage c'est la baie de somme on
évoquait tout à l'heure les cérémonies
de pâques les catholiques cherche les
nouvelles pratiques religieuses qui
attire les fidèles en voici une
le rock kato le festival de chartres a
encore fait le plein cette année
julia delage chili puis jointe sur place
avant à chartres
non bien de la pac c'était plutôt sans
aînés mais aujourd'hui finie la messe en
latin maintenant on célébrera fois on
rythmes rock punk et même reggae la
nouvelle scène chrétienne s'affirme
les jeunes adorent c'est la foi vivante
c'est la résurrection
l'espérance c'est mieux pour les jeunes
quoi ça bouge pousser ses plus vives
entre ce qui est mauvais parce qu'on
écoute c'est bien les l'orgue mais il ya
aussi le reggae et oya il faut profiter
de tout cela allait à l'église tout ça
arrive également les barreaux sont
vraiment magnifiques et la musique est
super nanas pour tous les goûts et
franchement c'était génial chanter
safwan n'est plus du tout ringard avec
plus de 6000 jeunes 13 ans à chartres
pour l'église
on est sur la bonne voie c'est pas parce
que il ya des milliers de jeunes qui
viennent au festival qui seront
forcément dès demain dans l'église
maintenant il faut aller dans la rue et
sonner les cloches dans la rue
c'est-à-dire là où les gens sont les
jeunes ils sont dans la rue des jeunes y
sont dans les concerts c'est là où on
peut les rejoindre c'est là qu'on peut
parler avec eux à côté des concerts on
fait aussi de bonnes affaires cd
marchandising accessoires on vend tout
mais avec la fois
bah c'est le rock ça fait mauvais
garçons et on en fait oui encore elle
qui m'a permis aux chrétiens
pour sa troisième édition le festival de
pâques compte sur près de 15000
personnes et la ferveur de la fois le
retour de daniel buren il est exposé
cette fois musée guggenheim de new york
il s'agit d'une oeuvre monumentale un
pan de mur de plusieurs mètres de haut
et comme à chaque fois l'exposition fait
beaucoup parler il y allait pour et les
contre isabelle bechler olivier robert
au guggenheim de new york frank lloyd
wright l'architecte avait déjà banni les
lignes droites mais là rien ne va plus
même les courbes sont brisées d'où la
perplexité où les sourires complices des
visiteurs de l'exposition de daniel
buren c'est la deuxième fois que
l'artiste français intervient
massivement dans le puits central de la
rotonde avec une sculpture de 30 mètres
de haut qui occupe un quart de son
volume sa première création en 1971
avait ulcéré les peintres américains et
sa tante sûrs rayé avait été ni plus ni
moins décrocher c'est la pièce que
personne n'a pu voir en vrai et qui se
trouvait ici à peu près où on est en
1971 et qui a été censuré avant
l'ouverture de l'exposition
l'objet qui occupe aujourd'hui le musée
est un véritable casse tête pour les
photographes amateurs ou non la réalité
sort toujours du cadre et a une fâcheuse
tendance à donner le tournis
la magie de l'intervention tient aux 75
tonnes de miroirs installés au
millimètre près par 30 ingénieurs et
ouvriers du bâtiment qui l'ont conçu et
monté comme un meccano géant en trois
semaines de travail nocturne la plupart
du temps
il ya des endroits où le musée quasiment
intact un touché et ça m'intéresse aussi
parce que je pense c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre du 20e siècle et d'un
autre côté on déconstruit le musée mais
c'est vrai que bah oui voyez ce en
faisant presque rien on est très
envahissant le guggenheim est ainsi
envahi de rayures pour 2 mois y compris
celles des fans qui s'ignore pour être
dans la norme de gurren elles doivent
mesurer et 8,7 cm de large c'est
l'orthodoxie même le vendeur de hot dogs
sur la cinquième avenue face au musée y
est elle est à rayures voilà comme prévu
retour à la principale information de ce
début de soirée maintenant ce nouveau
tremblement de terre en asie du sud en
indonésie quasiment au même endroit
qu'il y à trois mois l'alerté au tsunami
est générale dans la région
mais pour l'instant il nous retrouvons
fabienne sintès qui se trouve un
banda aceh et donc tout près du lieu du
séisme mais de l'autre côté de la côte
fabienne pour l'instant pas de tsunamis
signalé par les autorités
non pas du tout et le brix vous entendez
derrière moi ce sont les voitures et les
mobylettes
il faut qu'on prend les gens qui sont en
train de rentrer chez eux le grand
mouvement de panique de la première
alerte juste après le tremblement de
terre ce mouvement de panique est
terminé maintenant
la police a fait à peu près ce qu'elle a
pu ici pour dire aux gens de se calmer
qu'a priori n'y avait pas de raison de
craindre un tsunami
on a dû les gens restent existe encore
d'ailleurs extrêmement longtemps scruter
la mer en fait pour voir si le niveau ne
monte pas subitement et pour pouvoir
partir immédiatement certaines personnes
avec leurs enfants dans les bras avec la
voiture que d'un côté parfois même
moteur allumé pour pouvoir partir très
vite mais c'est dans là aussi
gloussements bon j'allais dire l'a
décrochée en fait et avoir moins peur et
rentrer chez eux
le camp nou vent de panique encore une
fois est passé ya pas eu d'évacuation
générale évidemment ici à banda aceh
juste un vrai moment de panique à un
souvenir incroyable qui remonté en fait
pour ces gens qui leur a rappelé de
manière tellement incroyable tellement
prégnante le 26 décembre qui sont partis
comme des fous tous avec leur voiture
immobile est vers l'est vers les
hauteurs ils sont doucement encore une
fois en train de rentrer doucement en
train de se calmer en train de se parler
en tout cas sur les pas de porte avant
peut-être enfin d'essayer de passer une
nuit à tremblements assez peu tranquille
ici quand même merci fabienne pour ce
témoignage
il faut dire et c'est ce qui explique
aussi peut-être ce mouvement de panique
que les informations étaient très
contradictoires en début de soirée juste
après ce séisme
puisque les états unis évoqué la
possibilité d'un tsunami dévastateur
quelques instants plus tard l'institut
géologique de strasbourg parlait d'un
séisme 30 fois moins puissant que celui
du 26 décembre on était à 8,2 sur
l'échelle de richter certaines autres
sources avaient parlé de 8.5 ont fait le
point en images sur les informations
dont nous disposons avec amaury guibert
voici les premières images en provenance
d'indonésie
peu de temps après la secousse les rues
de banda aceh sont envahi en voiture à
moto ou à pied
devant la peur d'un nouveau raz-de-marée
ils préfèrent fuir vers l'intérieur des
terres à des milliers de kilomètres de
là la même stupeur dans la norme nous
sommes à bangkok la capitale
thaïlandaise et en nombre les habitants
préfèrent quitter les bâtiments par
crainte des répliques
le séisme s'est produit peu après 18h
heure française une violente secousse de
8,2 sur l'échelle de richter l'épicentre
se situe au large de l'île indonésienne
de sumatra à 205 km de la ville de
sibolga sumatra qui avaient été durement
frappé le 26 décembre
on ignore pour le moment le nombre de
victimes ni l'ampleur des dégâts mais en
indonésie une alerte au tsunami a été
déclenchée même chose en thaïlande au
sri lanka et en inde
c'est le centre d'alerté des tsunamis du
pacifique basé à hawaï qui le premier a
lancé l' alerte parlant d'un possible
raz-de-marée dévastateur
il a aussi conseillé aux populations
d'évacuer les côtes pour éviter une
catastrophe semblable à celle du 26
décembre dernier
voilà en thaïlande nous retrouvons
philippe rochot tout de suite au
téléphone notre envoyé spécial bonsoir
philippe donc là aussi on l'a dit alerte
générale au tsunami
qu'en est il de la situation à l'heure
où l'on se parle le problème c'est qu'il
n'ya pas de dispositif d' alerte c'est à
dire que la lettre se dérouler à la
télévision à la radio mais il n'y a pas
eu de sirène par exemple dans les rues
de pocket pour demander aux gens
d'évacuer
en revanche il n'y a pas eu de tsunami
si les habitants se sont rendus sur les
hauteurs de façon assez calme et puis
maintenant on les voit le redescendre au
bord de la deûle amer et regardez ce qui
s'est passé il y a les bateaux qui sont
là il ya tout est intact et finalement
des gens qui avaient peur de revivre le
cauchemar du 26 décembre ne l'ont pas
vécu la terre a tremblé aussi un peu à
bangkok il ya eu quelques quelques
vitres cassées n'est rien de grave
la télévision thaïlandaise consacre bien
sûr tous ces programmes à l'évolution de
ce tremblement terre et tente maintenant
de rassurer les gens puisque il est
clair qu'il n'y aura pas maintenant des
fêtes une année dans la région après se
prend leur emploi à donner vie merci
philippe et il faudra bien sûr attendre
plusieurs heures peut-être plusieurs
jours pour avoir une idée des dégâts
provoqués en indonésie peut-être
ailleurs par ce tremblement de terre que
les experts américains ont décrit dans
un premier temps comme très puissant et
qui pouvait provoquer une vague
importante que les experts français en
revanche ont ramené à des proportions
beaucoup moins importante
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi et très bonne fin de week
end de pâques tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h55 l'homme pressé
avec anthony delon et mathilda may 22h40
à ne pas manquer un oeil sur la planète
peut-on encore ignorer le brésil l'année
du brésil à l'occasion de mieux
connaître ce pays émergents et souvent
fascinant avec thierry thulliez 00h30
dernier journal laurence piquet et on se
quitte sur ces images du festival de
l'oeuf de tourtour cela ce passe près de
nice et là bas c'est une tradition à
chaque week-end de pâques ces danses
folkloriques et défilé dans les rues et
le coup de manifestations
c'est cette bataille de le dimanche
après-midi des oeufs crus des lancers de
cruauté il le préciser à demain